[Music]
foreign
because I don't see any like at the end
of the tunnel of that bill my arrears is
getting more and more and I just feel I
can't pay it I can't believe I get up at
5am as a Harbor Master and have to check
the Brent crude oil prices to see
whether they're going up or going down
you're the ones that then don't get any
fuel for your car the food costs more
they're scared people are scared to turn
the heating on it's cold it's damp and
people are desperate to try and do
anything to save themselves energy the
boys are looking we're looking at one
another can't do anything about it
that's just how it is you know we can't
this this won't go out to sea for
nothing we've got to catch fish
hey Lara it's Dan here from Sky News
so the last time that we caught up with
Lara she told us she just canceled her
direct debits for her gas and
electricity she simply couldn't afford
it anymore of course since then all the
bills have gone up again
nice to see you again yeah six months on
what happened in the months after that
unfortunately I've I did have to cancel
it it's only just being reinstated this
month I'm now
nearly 600 pound in arrears
which is really worrying for me because
I've not got 600 pounds we had to go
bang pay it
the government's energy support payments
each month have helped but the fact is
Lara is now in debt
we've agreed that our paid 263 pounds
for more gas and electric and on top of
that 10 pound a month for the the 600
pound arrears oil
it is frightening because I don't see
any like at the end of the tunnel of
that bill my arrears is getting more and
more and I just feel I can't pay it
six months feels a long time ago when we
were here last summer was approaching
Boris Johnson was still prime minister
since then inflation and interest rates
are up as are all our bills
I'll bet it Plymouth city council has
set up a new multi-agency cost of living
task force it's needed says its creator
because requests for financial help in
the city are up
235 percent in the last year we know
that this time around the cost of living
impact is going to be high for everyone
because we all pay entity bills it's one
thing that we've all got in common isn't
it what is interesting is that we're
seeing that increase in Wards the
ordinarily don't contact them so my ward
in particular is in a more affluent part
of the city but the increase has been
seen there so it's still fairly small
numbers but the percentage changes is
quite significant brilliant do you want
to come on through yes lovely as part of
the new task force free home checks are
being offered to the over 50s in the
city the aim to reduce people's bills
but age UK Plymouth who run the scheme
so they've run out of kits because
demand is so high
veterans Ian and Annette don't get any
benefits and feel that those in the
middle aren't getting enough support
you're the ones that then don't get any
extra help and that money is then being
chomped up either with fuel for your car
the food costs more the energy bills
costs more
um
and yeah it's tough you know I mean you
asked about our curtains where you know
why were the curtains closed the
curtains are closed because one of the
measures we do is we keep the curtains
closed to keep the heat in do you want
to keep hold of these we've got a few
radiators that need doing it yep so
that's great
this is not a tale of pensioners sat in
the cold struggling to make ends meet it
is an example of how this charity is
having to spread its help to even more
in society
they're scared people are scared to turn
the heating on it's cold it's damp and
people are desperate to try and do
anything to save themselves energy
what's good about this scheme is that
yes a large proportion of it does need
to go to people who are on a low income
but there is a small percentage to help
that group in the middle who don't
necessarily claim means tested benefits
but equally are seeing that squeeze as
well
5 30 a.m Plymouth fish market
for those who've been out at Sea the
biggest squeeze at the minute is the
cost of fuel for the boat I can't
believe I get up at 5am as a Harbor
Master and have to check the Brent crude
oil prices to see whether they're going
up or going down or profit margins are
extremely small and we're trying to keep
it that way because we want to keep
boats at sea
foreign
[Applause]
the price of fish is strong but Mark
tells me the vulnerable nature of
hospitality is proving costly for them
one of one of my sort of uh clients
today spoke to me and said I've had to
cancel I I've had to cancel an order of
crabs so that was a thousand pounds in
weight of crab had been canceled because
a restaurant in London had closed all of
its restaurants the staff have been paid
up to Christmas he's now left with that
amount of excess meat which he's now
having to sell elsewhere so the knock-on
effects of people losing their jobs in
the hospitality industry is is driving
stuff up and down every single day you
are looking at colliding factors to
affect the fishing industry
Chris
in five years Chris Newman has fished
the waters around the Southwest but for
the last 12 months he's been trying to
sell his boat he says tight margins and
high costs are making the Next
Generation think twice about getting
into the industry fuel used to be sort
of five to ten percent of your gross now
it's 25 to 30 you know the boys are
looking we're looking at one another you
know we can't this this won't go out to
sea for nothing we've got to catch fish
what are all these costs mean for the
attractiveness of buying your boat and
getting into this well obviously people
don't want to do that do they they don't
want to spend
all this money and this is what it is
you know these boats need to gross a lot
of money so people don't want to work
that hard do they
you know especially when their fuel
costs are so much
[Music]
Plymouth is home to more than 260
000 people the city Falls within the 20
most deprived areas of England some
parts in the top one percent and as
temperatures start to fall the task
force is having to react
churches Village halls and community
centers have been placed on an online
map open to those unable to heat their
homes there's about 30 of these
so-called warm spaces in Plymouth of
course we see them up and down the
country and although it's a really
youthful place for people to come who
are struggling to pay their bills
actually for many here it's not about
the heating and keeping warm it's about
the community and their Mental Health
Sandra started coming to the warm space
at Saint Jude's church in the last
couple of months it's just such a very
friendly place to be I feel very
strongly for me
an activity of some kind most days is is
the best way for me to
manage my time and keep keep me on a
Level Playing Field how important are
spaces like this hugely hugely important
hugely and I think for a a city the size
of Plymouth 30 did you say 30 spaces
needs to be a lot more than that needs
to be hugely increased upon I think
there's going to be a lot of demand
definitely definitely running this task
force is costing Millions money which
councils can scarcely afford and while
it was initially set up for six months
realistically that'll be much longer
nobody knows whether the winter is going
to force people out of their homes so
that they come and use warm spaces but
what we've made sure is that those
spaces exist I hope that we don't have
to keep it going for too long but the
reality that we're facing at the moment
is that it could well be something
that's in existence for a couple of
years
looking back six months there's no
denying that things have got tougher in
Plymouth there is now action and help
but with the worst of winter still to
come nobody really knows if it'll be
enough
damn white is Sky News in Plymouth